هذا وقد عمل اضربوا شامل اليوم مختلف
المحافظات الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
حدادا على ارواح الشهداء الذين سقطوا في
عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه يوم امس في مخيم
جنين وقد اغلقت المحل التجاريه ابوابها
استجابه لدعوه الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى
الاضراب حيث تخيموا اجواء من الحزن والغضب
في الشارع الفلسطيني ياتي ذلك في وقت
يستعد فيه الفلسطينيون لتشييع الشهداء
السته
ظهر اليوم في مخيم جنين وفي مخيم عسكر
شرقي نابلس الذي نقل اليه الليله الماضيه
جثمان الشهيد عبد الفتاح خاروشه منفذ
عمليه حواره قبل اكثر من عشره ايام والتي
ادى الى مقتل مستوطنين اثنين
ويبقى معنا مراسله الجزيره سمير ابو شماله
من جنين صباح الخير سمير كيف يبدو الوضع
في جنين حيث انت
صباح الخير نحن الان في داخل مخيم جنين في
الشارع الرئيسي داخل المخيم والقريب من
مستشفى جنين الحكومي حيث بعد ساعه من الان
ستبدا مراسم تشييع الشهداء الذين سقطوا
برصاص جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يوم امسب
الى مثواهم الاخير في المخيم وفي البلدات
القريبه من مخيم جنين بالامس كان هناك نقل
لجثمان الشهيد عبد الفتاح الروسي المتهم
بتنفيذه عمليه او هجوم حوار المسلح قبل
نحو عشره ايام في مدينه نابلس وتم نقله في
ساعته الليل الفائته الى مسقط راسه في
مخيم عسكر شرقيه مدينه نابلس حيث يتم
تشييعه بعد نحو ساعه من الان الاضراب
الشامل قدعم عدد كبير من المحافظات
الفلسطينيه بدعوه من الفصائل والوطنيه
والاسلاميه وذلك حدادا على ارواح الشهداء
الذين سقطوا بهذه العمليه العسكريه وايضا
تمديدا باستمرار الاحتلال والمستوطنين
بجرائمهم ومجازرهم بحق الفلسطينيين على
مدار الايام الاخيره الماضيه الحداد هو
سيد الموقف في هذه في هذا المخيم وفي عديد
المناطق في الضفه الغربيه حيث اغلقت
المحالات التجاريه ابوابها وايضا هناك
تعطيل للحياه التعليميه والكافه مناحي
الحياه في داخل المحافظات وذلك ايضا في
عطله رسميه تسود في داخل المحافظات
الفلسطينيه بمناسبه يوم المراه العالمي
كعطله رسميه من قبل الحكومه الفلسطينيه
المؤسسه الرسميه الفلسطينيه وايضا الفصائل
الفلسطينيه هي ادانه هذه العمليات
العسكريه المستمره بحق الفلسطينيين والتي
تؤدي الى مزيد من الشهداء والجرحى بين
الفلسطينيين كتائب شهداء الاقصى الجناح
المسلح بحركه قناه كتائب شهد القسام
الشهيد عز الدين القسام الجناح المسلح
لحركه حماس صدرت بيان وقد زفت من خلاله
شهيديها في هذه القافله الجديده من
الشهداء وهما الشهيد الاسير المحرر عبد
الفتاح خروشي المتهم بتنفيذ هجوم حوار
المسلح والذي قالت انه منفذ هذا الهجوم
وايضا الشهيد الاخر هو معتصم صباغ وهو
القسامي حسب
اوضحت في البيان العسكريه الذي صدر عن
كتائب القسام مؤكده انها لن تتوانى في
الدفاع عن الشعب الفلسطيني اساء هذه
الهجمات هذا هذه التصريحات ايضا هي
تزامنت مع بيانات اخرى منفصله من فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لكتاب شهداء الاقصى
وايضا سرايا القدس الذين اكدوا بان هذه
الجرائم لن تنال من عزيمه الفلسطينيين في
مقاومه الاحتلال وايضا ان دماغ الشهداء لن
تذهب بدرا التي تسجيل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
سميره بوشماله شكرا جزيلا لك